If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears, then you will also appear with him. And,
Well, happy Sunday Church, uh, grace and peace to you from God,
our Father and the Lord Jesus Christ. After last Sunday, great Sunday,
celebrating what God has done in Nicaragua. Uh,
we get to be back today into this series through the book of Colossians that we
call Christ Above All How He's above all,
like we just sang powers and dominions and philosophies and everything else in
this world. He is above it. As we get into it today though,
I want to tell you about the last time that our family went to the circus. Uh,
you'll see why it was the last time here in a second. Um,
the lion Tamer had, uh, you know, the big cage they put out there,
the lion tamer had about six big cats in there with him. And, and you know,
he's teaching 'em how to do the tricks.
They sit on the platform and stand up and all those kind of things.
All because they know that he's gonna give them a bite of food whenever they do
whatever he asks them to do. Well, on this particular occasion this night, uh,
there was one tiger that when they led it into the cage with all the others,
you could tell he was pretty feisty, uh, that night specifically, at least.
And, and so he gets in there and as the man, you have to remember,
like as the man is teaching them or training them or asking them to do the
things, he's giving them a piece of food. But he's also got this really long,
thin stick kind of thing that if they don't do it immediately,
he'll smack 'em on the head or on the side to, to remind them, Hey,
you need to do this. Right? And,
and so on this particular occasion that feisty tiger,
he was asking him to do something and he hit him on the head with that thing and
that tiger came at him and the way the man responded,
you knew that was not supposed to happen that way. And,
and so he thankfully did not go all the way to what he could have done,
but it was clearly a frightening situation for that man.
Now, here's the funny part about this.
We're standing or sitting there with all these people around us,
and everyone was shocked that that was happening.
But think about it like that's a wild animal, right?
That that's, that's a wild animal. Not just fluffy on the couch at home,
the house cat that's fat and lazy. You know, like I can't do anything to you.
This is a wild animal that's a 600 pound machine that is
wired to kill things. And by the way, he's hungry in that moment, right?
We were shocked. People were shocked. Should we be,
listen, I think that's how many of us treat our sin.
We
treat sin like they treat this tiger where
we try to manage it, tame it,
try to keep it in its place so it doesn't do too much damage to us.
Listen, no, you can't. You shouldn't,
you should take that lion of indwelling sin inside you
and you should drag it out in the street and shoot it in the head, right?
That's what we need to do with it. Not try to manage it, tame it, keep it,
we need to kill it. In fact, John Owen said this a couple hundred years ago,
he said, be killing sin or sin will be killing you.
We, in other words, like if we don't see sin as dangerous,
if we try to manage it, if we try to keep it in its place,
it's going to destroy us.
We have to be ruthless with,
it's what we're gonna see today, in fact, in God's word. So turn two,
Colossians chapter three with me, verses five through 11 is where we'll be.
If you're not there already, don't know how to get to it, that's fine.
Colossians in the New Testament after long books of Romans one, two Corinthians,
Galatians, Ephesians, Philippians, Colossians. Uh,
chapter three is big number three under that.
And then verse five would be little number five underneath the three.
That's Colossians three, five, and we'll get to that whole section soon enough.
But initially, I want you just to see the first four words of verse five.
In my translation, at least, it may be the same in yours.
It'll be some variation of this, but it includes a big transitional word.
We look for these, right?
We wanna see how the structure of a book fits together.
But these are the first four words of verse five put to death.
Therefore, in other words,
the Colossians were to put to death everything that
we're about to see in verses five through 11. We, we've already said,
put to death your sin.
They were to put it to death because of
everything that's just come before. That's the word. Therefore,
it links us back to what was said.
So because of everything he said in chapters one, two,
in the first part of three, because of all that, put your sin to death.
So what was all that stuff? Well, you might summarize it with this. He,
he says,
put to death all that I'm about to tell you because you need to
remember where you've come from.
Remember where you've come from. That's chapters one and two.
In the first part of three, this is the story of what God has done. They,
they've seen this remembrance been put in front of them. Paul said, Hey here,
here's what God's done. Here's what God's done.
Remember these things then because of all of that,
here's what you do.
And so I wanna take you on just a really rapid fire journey through those first
two chapters. And the first part of chapter three,
what we've seen so far that Paul was reminding them about six things
that you can pull out. There's probably more, but,
but pull six things out to say. Here's what he wanted them to remember.
And first you go back to chapter one, verse 12. He's reminding them that the,
the Colossians felt disqualified by others, but in fact,
God the Father had actually qualified them.
God the Father had taken these people who were disqualified by these judaizers
who were putting all this extra stuff on the gospel saying, Hey,
you've gotta do this. You can't do that. You need to do these things.
And if you don't live as stringent of a lifestyle as we do, you're out.
And they felt disqualified from the gospel by that
action. But no, he says, remember, the Father has qualified you.
He's accepted you. He's made you worthy to be brought in.
He's given you the entry ticket into the church.
And so God says, don't think about disqualification anymore.
Your qualification is not based on you anyway.
Your qualification's based on how Christ lived and it was perfect
for you. That's what qualifies you. So remember,
disqualified now qualified
second in chapter one, verses 21 and 22,
Paul reminded them that they were alienated,
but now they're reconciled that these Colossians predominantly were
Gentiles, they were foreigners.
They were alienated from the covenant promises that God gave the Jews.
But now they've been reconciled. And look how it says it. Colossians 1 21,
you who once were alienated and hostile in mind doing evil deeds,
he has now reconciled in his body of flesh by his death in
order to present you holy and blameless and above reproached before him, right?
So it was Christ's death who brought them
into the family. They'd been excluded. Outcast. Second class, no,
you're in, you're in.
You're reconciled with God through his death on the cross,
the whole book of Ephesians,
the second half of it talks about how God takes that together and,
and makes what was once separated in chapter two,
that God unified in the church in chapter three.
Then verses four through six says how this,
how it plays out because God's made the two, the enemies,
the alienate, alienated ones. Now one. That's what he's talking about here.
Because their identification into this new body is not based on where they were
born or their ethnicity.
Their identification with Christ is what the key is here,
nothing else.
Chapter two then leads us to see that if they identified with Christ's death,
which is what reconciled them, they identify with his death,
then they can also rec, uh, identify with his resurrection death.
'cause Christ didn't stay dead. He rose.
And so they can identify with that resurrection as well,
which means that they were once dead in their sin, but now they're alive in Him
Once dead. Now alive. This is another thing to remember.
Don't forget you were dead in your sin. Now you are alive in Christ.
That's what Colossians two verses 12 and 13 says,
in which you were also raised with him through faith in the powerful working of
God who raised him from the dead. You who were dead in your trespasses,
uncircumcision of your flesh,
God made alive together with him having forgiven us all our trespasses.
Right? So dead people can't do much right? Yet.
That's where each one of us is spiritually before Christ.
That's where we all are because of our sin, unable to respond to him.
And we certainly can't bring ourselves back to life.
We needed someone else to do it.
We can't work our way outta that problem of death. We needed God who does this,
by definition, brings things to life. We needed him to bring us to life.
And he does through his resurrection.
In verse 13, you saw it that that prior to Christ,
we actually stand guilty before God because of our sin. But now forgiven,
guilty, now forgiven.
You're forgiven Christian. And and notice that's not just swept under the rug.
Under the rug. Remember right? This is paid for.
The concept of forgiveness is that it was paid for not just kind of
swept aside and remember how God forgave us. Chapter two,
verse 14. By canceling the record of debt,
the guilt that stood against us with its legal demands,
this he set aside, nailing it to the cross.
You remember this illustration I gave of,
of the reams of paper that hold your rap sheet,
all the sin you've ever done, all the sin you'll ever do,
stacked up sheet after sheet of paper that was nailed
to the cross where Jesus' hands held the nail,
it went through that rap sheet on the cross just as much nailed to the cross,
canceled the record of debt that stood against you. Guilty,
yes, you're guilty now forgiven through
the cross.
Paul even talked further about how those Colossians were then also free from the
law. They're free from sin, but they're free from the law.
Remember the end of chapter two, he talked about manmade rules, regulations,
don't do this, do this, don't handle that. Don't taste that. Don't touch that.
He's talking about these extra rules. People put on the gospel to say,
you've gotta do this to prove it.
You've gotta do this to ensure that you're a Christian.
You have to do all these things on top of belief
in Christ. You're free.
Because remember what he says there is that enslaves you again,
you are a slave to sin. You are a slave to the law that you have to do this,
but now you don't. Now you're not a slave to it. You're free from it.
You're free from your sin. You're free from the law to follow Christ,
free to follow him. Now, where before you were a slave to sin,
you were enslaved, but now you're free.
And then finally, last week or last time we saw in Colossians three,
one through four,
this idea of how the Colossians used to be before Christ.
They were exclusively here on earth. Everything about their minds,
everything about their actions, it was all sinful, all worldly, all earthly.
He says, no, actually in Christ, you're not below anymore. You're now above.
You're above in Him. You're above with him.
You've been raised with Christ.
You are in God at the right hand of the Father.
So that's where their minds ought to be because that's where they are
already. In a sense, they're, they're above,
not below anymore. And so again,
the therefore in verse five, I know it was rapid fire,
there's more to look into that. Go back and listen to all the,
I wanna go back and read the first couple chapters,
but the therefore in verse five points us back to all of that,
those six things, those six remembrances that Paul says,
don't forget this. And he says in verse five, therefore,
so it pointed the Colossians back to all of that as the source of the
way they can now live this life that he says next. Therefore,
because of who God is, because of all that, God's done.
Because he's coming back one day in verse four. Therefore
do what he is about to say.
And so what does he say before verses uh,
verse one of verse 10 of chapter one. He says,
walk in a manner worthy of the Lord, fully pleasing to him.
This is how you can verse six of chapter two,
walk in him as we have received him. He's saying, this is how you can do that,
by not forgetting everything that God has done.
And so what we hit now in chapter three,
verse five is this shift to how that new life plays out.
Right? So this has been the background, the basis, the source.
Now how does that life actually look?
'cause it's one thing to believe, it's one thing to,
to kind of understand the gospel in some form. Like you,
you get the concepts,
but it actually does something in your life.
You can't divorce the action, the the result from the belief.
That's what Paul's about to show us.
The rest of the next few weeks will show us what a new life looks like.
If you're qualified, if you're reconciled, if you're alive, if you're forgiven,
if you're above, then this is what you do now.
This is how you live now because that's true of you in
Christ. Starting with verse five of chapter three,
therefore put to death what is earthly in you.
Sexual immorality, impurity, passion, evil desire,
covetousness, which is idolatry. On account of these,
the wrath of God is coming. And these,
you too once walked when you were living in them.
But now you must put them all away. Anger, wrath, malice,
slander, obscene. Talk from your mouth. Do not lie to one another.
Seeing that you have put off the old self with its practices and have put on the
new self, which is being renewed in knowledge after the image of its creator.
Here. There's not Greek and Jew, circumcised and uncircumcised, barbarian,
scythian, slave free. Christ is all. And in all
God, we've seen a lot already in the last few minutes,
been reminded of these truths of who you are and what you've done.
But now we're confronted with this.
And so we pray that I, I pray for me,
for us that we would be confronted with what you want us to
see here. How to be different,
how to put off to put to death, what is old,
what is the previous version of us, and to put on the new,
but Holy Spirit, we, we need you to show us.
We need you to empower us how to do that. So make it clear today. God,
use these words for your glory. In Jesus' name,
amen. So first,
in light of everything Christ has done in light of all that he's made the
Colossians to be and all that he's done in you believer today,
here's the first thing. He says, put off the old self.
Here's how you respond. Put off the old self.
That's first and foremost here in verse five.
In fact, he says it a couple different ways. Verse five,
put to death what is earthly in you? The things that he says,
bring the wrath of God, which should be a warning sign for us. First of all,
this stuff that if I'm doing that brings the wrath of God, man,
I should be really worried about doing those things.
So put to death what is earthly in you? Verse eight, you must put them all away.
What are them? What are the things he's talking about? Well,
it's what the Bible calls the ways of the world, the sinful nature,
the selfish flesh that is inside of each one of us that drives
us to rebel against God. It's the things that we once walked in,
the one that we just lived in. In verse seven,
it says the things that characterized us pre Christ,
every one of us, sinful nature. By birth,
we have this pre-K Christ kind of life where we're sinners,
not saints. This is what he says.
But to the Colossians, he says, guys,
this is what your life was like before Christ redeemed you.
This is the definition of a life outside of Christ. It's all of these things.
It's no different for us.
One Corinthians six describes this in a different way that we are in this
just as much says, do you not know that the unrighteous,
those who are not made right before God, not justified before God,
they will not inherit the kingdom of God. And here's what you know,
characterizes people who are unrighteous not right with God. Do not be deceived.
Neither the sexually immoral nor idolaters, nor adulterers,
nor those who practice homosexuality nor thieves, nor the greedy, nor drunkards,
nor revilers,
nor swindlers will inherit the kingdom of God and such
were some of you. And listen,
don't just pick out the big ones. When you read lists like that,
you can kind of highlight a couple of those.
Did you see idolatry and greed also make you just as guilty before
God?
Like those are celebrated in our capitalistic culture.
But here it says no. It will actually separate you from God.
Yet praise God that verse 11 doesn't stop there.
And such were some of you, but you were washed,
you were sanctified, made, holy, you were justified,
made right in the name of the Lord Jesus Christ.
And by the spirit of our God. Here's his point.
He lists all this stuff and says such. Were some of you,
he's saying that kind of stuff doesn't characterize you anymore.
Yes, you were an adulterer. Yes, you were a liar,
but you're not an adulterer anymore. You're not a liar anymore.
Might you lust, might you still lie? But that doesn't make who you are.
It doesn't define you anymore. You have been redeemed,
you've been washed, you've been sanctified, you've been justified.
Remember how Colossians three seven says it?
It says in these you two once walked, that's past tense.
It says, when you were living in them, yes, that's ongoing,
but it's past You were you once walked.
This is characterizing you in a past tense term. And so he says,
since it's past,
that then is how and why you are able to put those worldly
ways to death because it's in your past.
It's not who you are anymore. Put it away.
Drag that lion out in the street and kill it because it's already
passed. It's not who you are in Christ anymore.
In fact, look again at Colossians three verse nine. It says,
do not lie to one another. Seeing that,
or because you might say there's a causal link here because you have
put off the old self with its practices.
But Paul assumes that if you're a Christian,
you already have put off the old self with his practices that it's a past
reality.
You remember the the sand plum bush illustration from a couple weeks ago.
What he's saying here is that your root is different Now
the root is different now.
You have already put off the old self. It's already past.
See, this is the essence that we're talking about, this whole thing.
When you talk about holiness obedience, here's what the essence is.
Christ has changed you Christian.
So be more who you already are in him,
that that's it. That's what we're talking about here. Christ has changed you.
So start living more like you already are in him.
We're not trying to attain something.
We already are something in him that we're just trying to live out more
faithfully. That's what this is saying.
You were these things once walked like this before,
this is what you used to be. But that's not who you are anymore.
So live it out. Live like it, okay?
But if you remember back in chapter two, he,
Paul spent a lot of time talking about how some people are adding rules onto the
gospel. If you do this, you don't do that,
then that's gonna help you overcome sin and you'll be set, right?
That's what he condemned. But here's what can happen for us.
You hear us and we talk about overcoming sin,
putting death to self, right? All these things, we talk about that.
And what our minds can do immediately is go to the same thing that they were
doing in chapter two, right? I gotta, I gotta stop doing that.
I gotta throw my phone away. I gotta bury my tv, I gotta, you know,
all these things. And we start to put rules on to say,
I can't do that stuff anymore. I gotta stay away from those kind of things.
And we can immediately think about mere external actions.
That's our first reaction.
It's not not wrong because those things are in the list here, right?
So we're not saying it's not about external action. Do whatever you want.
These things are still included. External actions,
things like he says in verse five, sexual immorality,
which that word is where we get our word pornography from.
Its definition is any sexual activity outside of the context
of marriage. And that's a male and a female, right?
That that's what we say outside of the context of that relationship for life.
Any sexual activity, pornography, it's wrong.
Impurity in that word. That verse is even closely related to that.
Like the culture of your life is impure. And just stop for a second,
how pervasive that temptation is in our culture today, right?
Like this is almost the number one thing that would distinguish by the way,
back in Colossae in this timeframe, a life of chastity.
Meaning you're gonna live a pure life outside of the context of marriage, right?
I'm gonna have no action sexually anywhere. I'm gonna reserve it for marriage.
That was a revolutionary concept back then.
It was a huge distinguishing mark for believers whenever they started living
like that. Is it not the same today
you're looked at like you're crazy if you say, no, I'm I'm,
I'm going to reserve that for my wife or I'm gonna reserve that for my husband.
It people think you're nuts, but how?
How much? That points to the faithfulness of God.
Whenever we choose to live like that,
it points to the distinction of the new instead of the old.
But that's an action that he lists here. Of course,
you also see in verse eight the word wrath.
I was trying to think of how to define that and, and I thought of dude, perfect,
the rage monster, right?
Just going off on everyone you can see and everything around you that is wrath,
malice. He says it's similar, but it's more like the disposition.
A means spirit of vicious disposition towards people.
Your demeanor is malicious, slander.
He mentions these are actions, right? Slander.
Any speech that is defamatory is abusive.
And we think slander is some kind of like news article. No, listen, it's gossip.
It's sarcasm. Used to hurt someone,
snarky comments. And we typically don't do that face to face.
Maybe you do sadly. But what happens is we do it online
or we do it behind people's backs.
Slander.
He says in verse eight, obscene talk.
This would be anything that would be considered dirty or inappropriate for
Christians to talk about. Ephesians 4 29 says it this way,
let no corrupting talk come outta your mouth.
But only such as it's good for building up as fits the occasion that it may give
grace to those who hear.
When you're saying things that tear someone down instead of building them up,
that's corrupting, that's obscene, not just bad words.
That's obscene talk. Two
verse nine adds lying to the list that's deliberately misleading. Others,
which by the way was the reason Ananias and Sapphira died in the early church.
'cause they lied.
So you've got all these external actions
that we immediately jump to say, I can't do this, I gotta avoid this. Yes,
we do need to put those things to death. We need to put them away.
We should absolutely stand on the fact that if you call yourself a Christian,
you should not be doing those things. None of us.
There's no room for it.
And that's true. Here's the reality though.
You can set up enough fences in your life to not do any of those things.
That's not a comprehensive list, by the way. There's a whole lot more.
But the actions, think about actions. You can set up enough rules in your life,
like you can tape your mouth shut. So you never say anything to anybody.
You could throw your phone away, you could throw your computer away.
You'd go live in the woods and never see anybody.
So you never have to interact with anybody. So you don't commit adultery,
you don't lie like you could. You could set up rules
to keep you from doing the external actions.
But did you see that's not the whole list.
The problem is there's more here.
It's just like what Jesus did in the Sermon on the Mount. Remember Matthew five,
he talks about the external action,
but he takes it a step further and he goes to the internal motivations for those
actions.
So we jump to external actions. I can't do this. I gotta set up rules. No,
that's not enough
internal motivations. Jesus said in Matthew five, I know you've heard,
it's not to commit adultery, that's fine. But I say to you,
if you even look with lust,
it's like you've committed adultery already in your heart. It's just as wrong.
Okay? So what
this says is that even those internal motivations, those thoughts,
we've gotta put those away.
We've gotta put those to death just as much as the actions
that Christians should not even be thinking in an old self kind of way.
I mean, verse five, he talks about passions. That's a,
a catchall word for the internal desires of our lives.
Now he's talking sexual desires, of course, but he's,
he's com encompassing all kinds of desires here.
But I wanna be careful because when we say desire,
that can actually be a good thing at times too. When I desire God,
when I desire my wife, right? Like those are good desires, but,
but verse five said, a lot of those desires can be evil too.
So we need to be careful with that. So passions.
So you also see covetousness here, which is the word is greed, basically,
which is labeled idolatry.
Like it's finding your worth and value and identity on earth, which you can do.
Whether you have a lot of money or you don't have any money at all.
You can be covetous, you can be greedy. It's what's in your heart, right?
He says that's idolatry. You see anger in verse eight,
that's the same word Jesus used in Matthew five when he talked about murdering
someone in your heart. He said Anger, that's that word right there.
And so notice that all of these are internal motivations.
They're things you cannot build fences around.
You can't keep yourself from doing it by taping your mouth or burying something
or throwing in the mouth in the trash. You can't do it because it's in here.
These are things that God must change in your heart
as you are actively putting them to death.
You've gotta see God do the work. Okay? Now,
how do you do that? Because the question is, I want to,
I still see this stuff creep back up in my heart and my life. Well,
how do I kill it? Well, there's many, many ways, of course.
But part of it's confessing sin to the Lord and to others,
asking brothers and sisters for help to overcome this, to hold accountable,
to memorize scripture that would attack it, to uh,
praying regularly to therapy if you need it to.
All kinds of ways to help put to death what is
earthly in you, even inside you.
But again, remember we keep going back to this verse nine,
the reason you can do all of that,
the reason you can put to death even what's inside of you spiritually,
is because that has already been done in your life.
You've already had the old self put off of you. It's already been put to death.
All that's already been defeated in Christ.
It's a past tense reality that you already have put off the old self in him.
And so now the practice of how to make it happen day by day in your life,
well, remember, God's qualified you to do it.
He's reconciled you into God above. You're alive.
You're forgiven of all of that. Even when you fail,
you're free from sins chains.
So you can pursue this putting off of the old self.
It's what Romans six says.
We know that our old self was crucified with him in order
that the body of sin,
this might be brought to nothing so that we would no longer be enslaved
to sin. For one who has died has been set free from sin.
It doesn't own you anymore.
So you can put it to death.
You can actively shed the old self, not because you can in yourself,
but because God is working in you to do that.
And he's done all think about those things. I said at the beginning,
the six things that the whole book of Colossians points us to something that God
has done. I love what John Owen continued to say. He said,
our greatest hindrance in the Christian life is not our lack of effort,
but our lack of acquainted with our privileges.
Just think of what God's done, what he's given you,
how much he has in store for you, and all his power, all his glory.
It's there for you, Christian. And we forget it.
We move on from it. We don't remember it.
We choose not to abide in it.
And we try and try and try on our own. It doesn't work.
Remember. And then kill.
Remember what he's done and then go after it.
But if you remember in our passage today,
that was not the only way to respond to all that
God's done,
all that He's given you in salvation to the work of God in your life.
There was something else he said to do as well.
We've put off the old self in Christ with its practices. Yes, but verse 10,
he says, you have also put on the new self,
put off the old self,
but also respond by putting on the new self.
The image is like this old, nasty, tattered,
grimy robe that you've ripped off. And,
and instead of just giving it to goodwill,
you throw it in the trash and burn it and throw it away like everything is gone.
No, you instead, not only take off,
you also put on the new self redeemed in Jesus.
You live out what you now are.
And so we're gonna see this a whole lot more next week as we look at the new
self, which is 12 through 17. But, but just think about this picture.
The old self gone, the new self Here, it's an image of creation, right?
In fact, second Corinthians five 17, therefore if anyone was in Christ,
he's a new creation. The old has passed away. The new has come.
So you see there's a reality of God creating something new. That's his picture.
Paul's painting here in this whole book.
Genesis one is in his mind as he goes back to Genesis 1 27.
Remember what it says about God creating mankind.
God created man in his own image, in the image of God, he created him.
Male and female, he created them. Verse 26, let us make man in our image,
our likeness. So he's saying, God created us.
God formed us in that way to begin with,
to reflect his image. We're formed by God. But,
but then you'd remember Colossians one 15,
that Christ is the image of the invisible God.
Meaning the perfect image that we remember failed
at, created to reflect. His image failed at it.
Tainted image, distorted image.
Christ shows up the perfect image of the invisible God. Now check this out.
Colossians three 10. We know our new self,
it says is being renewed in knowledge after the image of its
creator. What were we intended to do?
Reflect his image. We failed at it. Christ is the perfect image.
What are we now being reformed into
His image. You see how that works? Like Paul's mind is,
is all about genesis and creation and now a new creation,
a new kingdom that he's building and put putting together and reforming.
It's to reflect the image to the world.
But I want you to see in verse 10, that word being renewed,
that's a present passive participle, English majors.
You know what I'm talking about? But,
but what that means is that it's an ongoing action done to you
being renewed. It's something done to you that you're receiving.
Notice what you're receiving. God is doing the renewing.
God is giving you knowledge. God is shaping you into his image.
That's what second Corinthians three 18 says. We with unveiled face,
beholden the glory of the Lord are being transformed into the same image from
one degree of glory to another. For this comes from the Lord. Who is the spirit?
See that God's doing this. We're beholding him.
He's changing us into his image and he's doing it inside us.
We're being renewed to live this new
creation kingdom kind of life that we're gonna see next week.
And throughout the rest of Colossians. This is what he's doing.
He's stripped away the old self. He's saying it's dead. It's gone.
Don't live in it anymore.
Here's what it looks like to live a new life that you can because
God is doing it in you.
So listen, church believer,
remember this. This is who you are now.
This is who you are. If, if you are in Christ,
that means you're qualified, you're reconciled,
you're alive, you're forgiven, you're free.
You are in the Father who, Romans 8 29,
who has predestined you to be conformed to the image of his son.
This is what he's doing in you. He will make you like him.
If this is who you are, Christian,
put to death, what is earthly in you put to death,
what's still there from your old self?
Put away the things that look like the old person.
Be ruthless. Put it away. That's not who you are anymore.
It's not who you are anymore. And so externally, actions, yes. But internally,
all the motivations, all of those things in you put it all away
because of what God's done for you.